si l'histoire générale de la réunion au
18e
c'est bien connu trop rares sont les
documents qui permettent d'entrer dans
l'intimité des personnages de l'époque
d'où l'intérêt que m'ont paru présenter
les nombreux écrits laissés par henri
paul un panneau des bassins en
particulier le récit des deux voyages
qu'il a fait en france en 1785 depuis
1790 6 792 et la volumineuse
correspondance qu'il a échangé avec des
parents et amis c'est à décrypter la
masse foisonnante de ces documents que
je me suis attaché dans mon livre
cherchant à retrouver tous les aspects
d'une personnalité complexe et
attachante
tout d'abord j'ai découvert des
informations sur son physique celle d'un
vigoureux quinquagénaire pendant son
voyage en france
très amoureux de la vie et gourmands
ainsi que gourmet puis sur sa position
financière et sociale celle d'un très
riches propriétaires possédant en 1800
plus de 400 esclaves et disposant en
métropole d'un impressionnant réseau de
relations mais ce qui m'a surtout
intéressé c'est la personnalité intime
de l'homme
d'abord un homme qui est s'avère être un
père attentif et attentionné
très soucieux de l'éducation et de la
réussite des sept enfants qui un moment
l'accompagner en métropole puis un homme
très curieux de tout très avides de
connaître tous les aspects du monde
nouveau qu'il découvrait depuis les
fastes de versailles jusqu'au quartier
les plus humbles de parc en suivant pas
à pas en ripolin j'ai ainsi découvert un
très fin observateur de la société de
l'époque jamais les pourvu de sens
critique voire d'une certaine causticité
et en même temps fortement imprégnée de
l'esprit des lumières catholique sans
outrance et surtout francs-maçons
convaincu mais cet homme il a été
confronté à un véritable cataclysme
social et politique celui des débuts de
l'époque révolutionnaire
quels furent ses réactions à ce
phénomène
allant du rejet à certain enthousiasme
quelles sont les questions que j'ai
également essayé d'aborder dans mon
travail
en définitive je dirais que j'ai essayé
de ne rien laisser dans l'ombre des
multiples aspects de ripolin pas long
des bassins
d'où le titre un brin provocateur je le
reconnais que j'ai donné à mon ouvrage
une véritable autopsie le top-6 d'un
homme foncièrement insulaire
foncièrement bourbonnais et fier de
l'être
mais en même temps très représentatif de
l'esprit de son temps l'époque des
lumières